y
[Música]
la cápsula cruz dragón de spacex se
acopló esta madrugada a la estación
espacial internacional para dar inicio a
una misión de seis meses liderada por el
francés thomas pesquet u2 después los
cuatro astronautas del equipo se
encontraron con la tripulación que ya
estaba en la estación espacial
tenemos análisis
hoy se cumplen 106 años del inicio del
genocidio de armenia cuando los turcos
otomanos arrestaron y decapitaron a
cientos de líderes armenios un total de
15 millones de armenios fueron
asesinados durante la primera guerra
mundial se espera que el presidente de
estados unidos joe biden reconozca
oficialmente esos hechos como un
genocidio tenemos reportes desde eeuu
y eeuu reanuda la vacunación con johnson
y johnson después de que la
administración de medicamentos y
alimentos de eeuu fda
junto con el centro de control y
prevención de enfermedades existieran en
que los beneficios son mucho mayores que
los riesgos esto después de que la
nación superará los 200 millones de
dosis aplicadas
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí en las 24 mi
nombre es liliana valencia
la cápsula cruz dragón de spacex se unió
esta madrugada a la estación espacial
internacional luego de casi un día de
viaje a más de 27.000 kilómetros por
hora
a bordo llegaron cuatro son autos entre
los cuales está el francés thomas
pesquet se trata de una misión que se
prolongará seis meses en experimentos
científicos de microgravedad hace pocos
minutos los tripulantes se encontraron
con el equipo que ya estaba en la
estación espacial y desde allí
ofrecieron una rueda de prensa donde
expresaron su satisfacción por el
encuentro estamos muy emocionados por
ser parte de esta histórica misión con
las dos tripulaciones de la cápsula
dragón a bordo es la primera vez que se
reutiliza una cápsula la primera vez que
se reutiliza un propulsor es un logro
tremendo de nuestros compañeros de
spacex así que quiero felicitarlos y
agradecerles estamos emocionados y
listos para empezar a trabajar hay
muchas cosas grandiosas que se que
haremos pues vamos a toulouse en el sur
de francia al centro de astronomía
científica desde se encuentra nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz natalia
bienvenida nuevamente y cuéntenos que
representa este encuentro para ellos y
para la misión canal desarrollar
muy buenos días pues la verdad es que
ver a estos 11 astronautas que se están
tomando justamente en este momento la
foto de familia pues es muy emocionante
aquí se vio con mucha emoción con muchos
aplausos porque significa también pues
la una exitosa cooperación internacional
el resultado de este de este éxito de
ver a los astronautas que representan a
las cuatro agencias espaciales allí
juntos y en particular pues para los
tripulantes de crudos que acaban de
llegar a bordo de la cápsula cruz dragón
y que fueron pues le dieron la
bienvenida desde tierra cada uno de
digamos de los jefes de las estaciones
de las agencias espaciales el primero en
hacerlo fue steve quien es el director
de la nasa y les decían además pues que
esto representaba también algo muy
importante en este momento en el mundo
que se está viviendo un momento tan
difícil pues sé que ellos eran esperas
ahora después pues de esto de esta foto
de los 11 incluso de los 12 porque a
bordo también están win win que es el
peluche un pingüino de peluche que
llevaron a cabo cruz dragón esta es una
tradición en el espacio pues viene un
tiempo muy cronometrado todo
habita en la tarde tendrán digamos un
briefing de seguridad y ya se sabe que
no va a ir a dormir y luego será crudos
15 minutos después podrás natalia por la
información desde tu luz y para analizar
también esta noticia nos comunicamos con
diego mardones astrónomo de la
universidad de chile- y ph en
astrofísica de la universidad de harvard
bienvenido a france 24 cuéntanos hoy
vimos cómo la cápsula cruz dragón de
spacex se acopló con la estación
espacial internacional que implica esa
manera en términos científicos y que
interacción va a haber entre ambas
tripulaciones
y el interés científico es cuando
experimentos que van a suceder en la
estación espacial lo más notable es el
haber reutilizado el cohete en la
cápsula de esa cosa es realmente
emocionante porque cambia la forma de
llegar al espacio es realmente una nueva
forma de hacerlo y es maravilloso que lo
lograron y mirando la imagen de uno no
puede decir o emocionarse de ver a estas
dos tripulaciones abrazándose en varilla
en el mundo de hoy pero que sí cuéntanos
muy rápidamente qué interacción va de 3
a 2 y placeres durante esos seis meses
de emisión van a trabajar juntas
mira todos trabajan juntos pero cada uno
con misiones separadas cada individuo
cada persona tiene su rol y tienen y
cada uno va realizando experimentos
distintos tiene sus horarios entonces el
ente
uno no sé cómo decir si quieres hay
interacción o la verdad es que si todo
en la estación espacial es colectivo
pero siempre con turnos y roles
separados no no van dos personas a
trabajar juntas en un mismo experimento
en el mismo momento que todo está
rotativo pues durante esta misión de
seis meses los astronautas desarrollarán
experimentos científicos de
microgravedad qué significa esto y para
qué sirve ese tipo de experimentos qué
conocimientos pueden aportar a la
ciencia entonces con esta tripulación y
este gran logro que se está teniendo hoy
la microgravedad es esencialmente cuando
uno no experimenta la gravedad si uno
bajará en un ascensor sin alambres y uno
cuando salta en caída libre no
experimenta gravedad porque no se la
cabeza y los pies están cayendo con la
misma aceleración uno se da cuenta que
fija la gravedad en cambio del suelo el
suelo es quien te afirma en el espacio
entonces cuando estás en órbitas no en
principio no se siente gravedad pero si
hay un poquito muy poquito que se nota
como que te tira un poco es un lado por
eso se llama microgravedad
de todas las cosas que se hacen en la
estación espacial todos los experimentos
biológicos o químicos de crecimiento de
cristales de formación de sólidos de
estructura de líquidos bajo
microgravedad son diría yo lo más
esencial porque es lo que lo que de
ninguna manera puede realizar en la
tierra entonces los experimentos de
micro gravedad son si uno tuviera que
escoger sólo una cosa todo lo que le dan
la razón de ser a la estación espacial
y bueno para terminar muy rápidamente
cuéntenos de la tripulación ya estábamos
viendo algo las condiciones en las que
van a vivir por supuesto sin gravedad
pero qué otro tipo de condiciones
podemos resaltar durante los próximos
seis meses y qué consecuencias podrían
tener en esta misión para el estado
físico los tripulantes
bueno hay que recordar que llegamos a
estación espacial durante desde los 70 y
esta estación espacial en particular se
comenzó a construir hace unos 20 años
entonces lleva a ha habido gente en el
espacio por períodos de meses hasta
pedidos de un par de años ahora en
períodos de seis meses es bastante
significativo la disminución de la masa
muscular sobre todo disminución de la
masa ósea entonces los astronautas
tienen durante su estadía un régimen que
incluye hacer deporte bajo condiciones
bien extrañas
sin gravedad que uno puede correrse en
gravedad bueno se las arreglan para
hacer ejercicio para disminuir los
efectos dañinos sobre la masa ósea de
masa muscular
y eso ya se ha conocido muy bien pero
toda la el día a día es muy difícil
dormir como duermes tú cuando estás
flotando te fijas te ves que como
llamarte a una cámara todo
como comes como tus necesidades
todo eso es único pero ya sabemos cómo
hacerlo ya lleva más de 20 años claro
que sí pues agradecemos a diego mardones
por su análisis y cambiamos de
información porque se cumplen 106 años
del genocidio de armenia ocurrido en el
año 1915 durante el cual el imperio
turco otomano asesinó y expulsó del país
a cientos de miles de líderes
intelectuales y activistas armenios
nuestra corresponsal en ereván beatriz
arslanián estuvo esta mañana en los
actos de homenajes a las víctimas me
encuentro en el memorial del genocidio
armenio de yereván donde en este momento
se están realizando los actos oficiales
del aniversario 106 de las masacres
perpetradas por el estado turco en ese
momento el imperio otomano contra el
pueblo armenio a raíz de la cual más de
un millón y medio de armenios fueron
masacrados
ayer por la noche se realizó la marcha
de las antorchas hasta este memorial y
ahora se reciben las visitas oficiales
de las autoridades de armenia a las
cuales también se sumó más de una decena
de delegaciones de diferentes partes del
mundo casi 30 países reconocieron
oficialmente el genocidio armenio
siguiendo los pasos de uruguay en 1965 y
luego también lo hizo francia en el 2001
muchas concepciones han cambiado en la
sociedad armenia a raíz de la última
guerra de nagorno garapa y por supuesto
han renovado los reclamos del pueblo
armenio ya no se trata solamente de lo
que ocurrió hace 106 años sino también
de lo que el pueblo armenio vivió hace
tan solo algunos meses cuando azerbaiyán
con el apoyo explícito de turquía atacó
el territorio de nagorno hogar a paz
desencadenando una guerra a gran escala
en la cual la población civil también
fue foco de ataque
y la administración de medicamentos y
alimentos de eeuu fda y el centro de
control y prevención de enfermedades
autorizaron reanudar la vacunación con
el fármaco monodosis de johnson y
johnson que fue pausada el pasado 13 de
abril para registrarse algunos casos de
trombos las autoridades sanitarias
federales insistieron en que los
beneficios son mucho mayores que los
riesgos
luz verde para retomar la vacunación con
el fármaco de johnson and johnson en
eeuu las autoridades sanitarias
federales autorizaron que se vuelva a
usar la vacuna de jums en cuyo uso fue
pausado el 13 de abril tras haberse
registrado algunos casos de coágulos
sanguíneos
para ser claros ya no recomendamos la
pausa de la vacuna de johnson and
johnson y las cifras registradas recogen
que 15 personas desarrollaron trombosis
de las cuales tres fallecieron entre
casi ocho millones de receptores del
fármaco
el centro para el control y prevención
de enfermedades y la afe
concluyeron este viernes que los
beneficios de la vacuna son mucho
mayores que sus riesgos además
recordaron las ventajas de que la vacuna
de johnson and johnson sea monodosis y
requiera una refrigeración convencional
a no temperaturas extremas bajo cero
tras una extensiva revisión de los datos
disponibles la rda y el cdc concluyeron
que la posibilidad de que ocurra el
llamado síndrome de trombosis
trombocitopenia es muy bajo aunque
seguiremos investigando sobre los
potenciales riesgos de la vacunación
ambas agencias tenemos plena confianza
en que los potenciales beneficios de
esta vacuna superan los potenciales
riesgos en individuos mayores de 18 años
la inoculación con la dosis de johnson
and johnson podría retomarse este mismo
sábado a quienes opten por esta vacuna
se les proporcionará una advertencia
sobre los posibles pero muy raros
riesgos la posición adoptada por las
agencias estado
coincide con la de la agencia europea
del medicamento respecto a la vacuna de
janssen pero también en relación con la
de astrazéneca el mismo viernes la ema
insistió en la necesidad de usar el
fármaco de oxford después de que varios
países se plantearán inocular una
segunda dosis de otra vacuna a las
personas que ya recibieron la primera de
astrazéneca
tras dos jornadas de encuentro finalizó
la cumbre virtual sobre el clima
convocada por el presidente de eeuu joe
biden
pese a las rivalidades con naciones como
china o rusia los 40 participantes se
enfocaron en crear mayores compromisos
para reducir las emisiones contaminantes
y avanzar hacia economías sostenibles
más detalles con valentina torres
un reto que permitirá crear grandes
oportunidades para trabajadores en todas
las naciones así fue como el presidente
de eeuu joe biden se refirió a la lucha
contra el cambio climático es una
oportunidad para crear millones de
trabajos bien pagados alrededor del
mundo en sectores innovadores trabajos
que traerán una mejor calidad de vida y
mayor dignidad para las personas que los
realizan y el mandatario pidió que los
esfuerzos se centre precisamente en
ayudar a los trabajadores que han hecho
parte de las industrias que quedarán en
el pasado para garantizar su futuro y
aplaudió que naciones con las que eeuu
tiene tensiones en otras áreas muestran
su compromiso con acabar con la
industria del carbono me siento animado
por el llamado que hizo el presidente
putin ayer para que el mundo colabore y
avance en la eliminación del dióxido de
carbono y eeuu espera trabajar con rusia
y otros países en ese esfuerzo en la
segunda jornada del turno fue para
líderes como el presidente del gobierno
español pedro sánchez que celebró el
regreso de washington al acuerdo
ambiental de parís y el primer ministro
de israel benjamin netanyahu que se
comprometió a que su país no quemara
carbón para
25 el encuentro en el que eeuu aseguró
que logrará la neutralidad de emisiones
en 2050 uniéndose a la meta de la
comunidad europea es la antesala de la
cob 26 cumbre mundial del clima que se
celebrará en noviembre en la ciudad
escocesa de glasgow en la que se
concretarán los anuncios hechos
los líderes de la asociación de naciones
del sudeste asiático asean se reúnen
este sábado en yakarta la capital de
indonesia para analizar posibles
soluciones a la crisis social y política
que se vive en mi alma tras el golpe de
estado del pasado primero de febrero
general golpista birmano min online está
presente en el encuentro los dos
mandatarios informaron que alcanzaron un
consenso sobre cinco puntos encaminados
a resolver la crisis en mianmar donde
centenares de personas han muerto y
almería a manos de los militares en casi
tres meses de protestas así finalizamos
continúen con más hembras 24 punto com
[Música]